hey guys it's Monday May second and your
regular host Jess McDonald is somewhere
on a top secret mission I can't talk
about it but I'm sure it's cooler than
what you or I are doing today so we're
in this together I'm Mary and this is
gamespot news fer stuff you remember
that triple leak from last week the one
about Cod's new name the new release
date and the secret game you get with it
it's all true all of it that's right
Activision has officially announced call
of duty infinite warfare the game is
scheduled for release worldwide on
November fourth for ps4 xbox one and pc
and as expected it's developed by
infinity ward call of duty infinite
warfare will introduce an entirely new
setting for the Call of Duty series I
bet you didn't expect this it's space
Call of Duty's been in space before but
this one space ear the game's campaign
will feature new weapons and abilities
and take the player on a journey from
boots on ground combat to piloting
high-speed space fighters Activision
described it as a near seamless
experience with few visible loading
times air and space combat will be a key
aspect of the campaign while multiplayer
and zombie modes were also confirmed
details were scarce zombies will be a
co-op mode featuring a new storyline and
unique mechanics more information on
both modes will be released later this
year but get to the important stuff call
of duty infinite Warfare's legacy
Edition will include a true
high-definition remaster of 2007's call
of duty 4 modern warfare the full
campaign from 2007 game is included and
there's also multiplayer however the
online multiplayer mode is limited to 10
fan favorite maps the full list was not
announced but the confirmed map so far
our crash back lot and crossfire there's
two things we know about game
development one the release dates are
never accurate to the budget is always
way under what it actually should be and
a dev is saying that epics version of
Gears of War for would cost a hundred
million to make is part of a new polygon
feature on the history and future of
Epic Games CEO Tim Sweeney talked about
why the company underwent something of a
switch as it relates to development and
business models in the story Sweeney
spoke about how the Gears of War
franchise is ballooning budget along
with disagreements with Microsoft played
a part in epics
decision to focus more on free-to-play
sweeney revealed that the 2006 original
Gears of War for xbox 360 cost 12
million to develop and ended up taking
around 100 million in revenue it was
very profitable he said however the
budgets for the follow-ups grew
substantially with gears of war 3
estimated to have cost around four or
five times as much as the first game so
48 to 60 million math the plan epic had
for Gears of War for before selling the
franchise and Microsoft would have been
about a hundred million dollars the
Prophet was shrinking and shrinking he
said about gears of war we calculated if
we built Gears of War for the budget
would have been well over a hundred
million and if it was a huge success we
would break even anything less would put
us out of business years of war for is
in development at Microsoft's to do the
coalition the game's multiplayer beta
wrapped up this past weekend while the
full launch is slated for october
eleventh on the xbox one and finally
some good news mighty number 9 has a
release date no real like it's a real
really say this time it's June
twenty-first mighty number nine that new
platformer from Mega Man designer keiji
inafune a has crossed a new development
milestone it was announced today that
the game has gone gold meaning
development on the game which was
delayed multiple times is super finished
for reals it's going to be available
June twenty-first in a statement inna
foon a apologize for the games multiple
delays and thanked fans for their
patience most recently mighty number
nine was slated to arrive in spring of
2016 a window it's missing with its now
june release date firstly I'd like to
say again how sincerely sorry we are for
how long we've kept all our fans waiting
we understand that as a result of the
various delays we have disappointed and
let down our fans but we're happy to
finally be able to deliver the game to
everyone who brought us this far
development team is now completing the
last final stages of production inna
funa also promised there will be no more
delays for realz the release date we are
announcing is set in stone and there
will be no further delays for the game
mighty number 9 will launch God willing
June twenty-first for ps4 xbox one ps3
xbox 360 wii u and even PC versions for
the game for nintendo 3ds and
playstation vita will also come but a
delay
point so that's all the news I have for
you today Jess McDonald will be back
tomorrow taking back the reins queen of
GS news and my heart I'll see you guys
later
you